[Music]
a virtual private cloud or VPC refers to
a virtual network for your AWS account
in the AWS cloud a VPC is logically
secluded from other virtual networks to
ensure powerful networking and security
for your compute resources a subnet in
Amazon VPC refers to a segment of the
range of IP addresses and is a
subdivision in an availability zone
preferred instances are launched into
this subnet a subnet allows you to group
instances according to your operational
and security requirements Amazon VPC
allows launching AWS resources into the
virtual network which is a logically
isolated area containing cloud resources
for Amazon ec2 Amazon VPC acts as the
networking layer as you pay only for its
used resources there is no additional
cost for the using of Amazon VPC service
it is similar to a traditional network
running in your data center but allows
to use the scalable AWS infrastructure
and enjoy complete control over your
virtual network with Amazon VPC you can
select from a range of IP addresses
create subnets
and configure network gateways and
routing tables it also gives you the
power to customize the network
configuration for example you can place
the backend systems such as database
servers in a private subnet and web
servers in the public subnet for
connecting to the Internet you can also
connect the Amazon VPC to your data
center by establishing a virtual private
network or VPN connection this helps in
rendering the AWS cloud as an extension
of your data center with Amazon VPC you
can also leverage several security
layers by including access control lists
or ACLs
and different security groups this
enables you to control access of
instances in each subnet the significant
benefits of Amazon VPC are first it
offers several connectivity options for
example you can connect the Amazon VPC
to other VP C's your data center
internet and based on the AWS resources
you choose to make public or private
second it is easy to create an Amazon V
PC in minutes using the AWS management
console while creating a V PC AWS
automatically assigns the security
groups IP ranges subnets and routing
tables as a result you can focus on
creating the applications that will run
in the V PC third Amazon V PC offers
advanced security features such as ACLs
and security groups to filter inbound
and outbound traffic these features are
available at the subnet and instance
levels you can even restrict access to
the stored data so that it is accessible
only from the instances in the V PC AWS
even lets you run instances on Hardware
of a single user for additional
isolation
lastly you enjoy the scalability and
reliability benefits of AWS Amazon V PC
offers all benefits that the remaining
AWS platform provides you can
immediately scale the resources pay only
for the resources used and specify types
of instances suitable for your
applications by launching the instances
into a V PC you can run instances on the
hardware used by a single entity split
the range of private IP addresses of V
PC into one or more private or public
subnets to run services and applications
in that V PC allocate multiple IP
addresses to the instances allocate
static private IP addresses to the
instances
that continue to run across starts and
stops define network interfaces and
associate one or more interfaces into
your instances control the inbound
traffic to instances which is known as
ingress filtering and control the
outbound traffic from instances which is
known as egress filtering add an extra
layer of access control to instances
which is in the form of ACLs change the
membership of security group of
instances when they are running in each
availability zone
the default VPC contains a subnet it is
ready to use and offers the advanced
features of the ec2 VPC platform when
you do not mention a subnet despite
having a default VPC the Amazon ec2
instance launches into your default V PC
despite having an AWS account that
supports only the ec2 V PC platform you
can create and configure a VP C as per
your requirements the additional subnets
in the default V PC and subnets in a
non-default V PC are termed as non
default subnets when you open the V PC
wizard it shows four scenarios there are
four basic network topologies and you
need to select the one that resembles
the topology you wish to create V PC
with a single public subnet scenario or
topology V PC with public and private
subnet V PC with public and private
subnets and hardware VPN access V PC
with a private subnet only and hardware
VPN access V PC with a single public
subnet allows running a single tier web
application to be made publicly
available such as a simple website or a
blog you can ensure the security and
privacy of such applications by defining
the security group rules that enable the
web server to respond to the incoming
and outgoing requests
VPC with public and private subnets
allow running a public web application
and ensuring the private back-end
servers continue to run in another
subnet you can use this scenario to host
multi tier web applications and
enforcing access restrictions between
databases application servers and web
servers through security groups and ACLs
you can launch the application servers
and databases in private subnets and web
servers in public subnets the
application servers and databases can
access the internet to download and
install patches when you set up a
network address translation or na T
gateways the na T gateway allows
instances in a private subnet to connect
to other AWS services including the
internet but prohibits the AWS services
to connect with instances in the private
subnet this ensures higher bandwidth
with less administrative effort VPC with
public and private subnets and hardware
with VPN access allows accessing the
World Wide Web directly from your V PC
it also facilitates expanding your data
center into the AWS cloud you can
consider this option for hosting
scalable web applications connected to
your data center this topology allows
creating a V PC where instances such as
web servers in a subnet connect to the
World Wide Web at the same time
instances such as application servers in
the other subnet communicate with
databases of your business network
application servers and web servers can
take the benefits of auto scaling and
Amazon ec2 features to scale when needed
to secure all communications between the
databases in your data center and
application servers in the cloud you can
set up an Internet Protocol security or
IP SEC VPN connection between them V PC
with a private subnet only and hardware
VPN access allows leveraging the
infrastructure of AWS without exposing
your network to the World Wide Web
it also facilitates expanding your data
center into the AWS cloud with this
topology it is possible to introduce
more web servers move business
applications to the cloud and increase
the computing capacity by associating
the network with your V PC by hosting
your V PC behind the business firewall
you can
effortlessly move the IT resources into
the cloud without modifying how the
end-users can access them let's see the
steps to create in Amazon VPC under the
networking services click VPC to display
the Amazon VPC console
before we create or access an Amazon V
PC it is important to note that if your
AWS account was created after December
4th 2013 there is already a default V PC
assigned to your account such accounts
with a default V PC support only the ec2
V PC platform
additionally there are restrictions to
the number of V PC components such as
security groups and routing tables that
you can set up if you wish to increase
these limits you can request for the
same in the console dashboard click
start V PC wizard to display the page
select a V PC configuration
it is important to note that this is the
first out of the four steps to create an
Amazon V PC here click select to create
your V PC a page for the second step V
PC with a single public subnet is
displayed
it shows default configuration setting
if you wish you can modify the
configuration settings IP CIDR block
shows the IP address range for your V PC
here enter the V PC name as V PC - one
the public subnet field shows the IP
address range for the subnet the
availability zone list allows you to
select the availability zone where you
need to create the subnet for this
demonstration we will select no
preference this way
AWS automatically assigns an
availability zone in the add endpoints
for s3 to your subnet section select a
subnet that will create a VPC endpoint
for your Amazon s3 bucket in the same
region for this demonstration we will
select the option as none then set the
enable DNS host names option to yes this
will ensure that instances launched onto
your V PC receive a DNS hostname next
the hardware tenancy option enables you
to select whether instances launched
into your V PC run on shared or
dedicated Hardware for this
demonstration we will keep it as default
next click create V PC to display a
status window
you
in this window once your work is
completed click OK to close the status
window
congratulations you have successfully
created in Amazon VPC hey once become an
expert in cloud computing then subscribe
the simply learn Channel and click here
to watch more such videos turn it up and
get certified in cloud computing click
here